Brandi Glanville says she and LeAnn  Rimes are finally yes finally in a good  place the famously single star opened up  about raising kids with our ex-husband  Eddie Cibrian and LeAnn on Sirius XM  well I think that I've acted like a  child enough during the seven years  we've definitely had our moments of not  putting that good first and not being  proper adults it made the three of us  Atlanta myself like realize we have to  be together on this we have to be a unit  we have to stick together in order to  keep these little boys in line we just  came together and it's all fine and I  think that LeAnn finally realizes I  don't want your man yeah you know that's  all done but we can all stuck at along  be friends that's all good to hear  because last year Brandi explained the  struggles of co-parenting to et you know  there's gonna be fights about you know  parenting styles and whatnot and I will  scream and y'all love it